on to a not-so-good note tell us what
happened on Sunday in Oxnard on your
final show with a guy been sitting in
the front the Down syndrome guy not the
Down syndrome buddy but oh my god yeah
so um you know I have a joke about I
have a joke that I tell you're not to
say no I'll just give you the gist of
the joke but there was a joke I have
where I have a joke about people Down
syndrome having sex yeah
and so I'm about to tell the joke and
this older man in the audience in the
front row goes my son has Down syndrome
yes tears in his eye tears in his eyes
and I look at him I go you're being for
real yeah down syndrome I go well I hope
you enjoy the joke what else that's the
answer that's I mean you can't stop yeah
I'm if okay listen I tell comics this
all the time is if you have a joke where
you can't tell it in certain rooms
because of who's in the room they should
never tell the joke because you know
it's just not then it's beyond your set
but if I'm gonna tell it I'm going to
tell it no matter who's in the room
because you know I believe in the joke
and I believe in America America and I
believe in free speech and all that
stuff yeah so it wasn't gonna stop me
from telling a joke but it didn't go
well yes it did
well yeah it did because at the end yeah
he did laugh hysterically it's just that
the rest of the audience felt bad they
were kind of like the whole audience
while saying they're real bad he was
laughing a very and oh yeah at the very
end cuz I'd go into the sex moves yeah
yeah I mean and they it got to him but
um like it's like I tell the joke about
Alzheimer's it's kind of really nice but
and people some people don't like it I
mean it's like I can't you can't write
jokes you know based on how people are
gonna feel about it
I don't care yeah I mean I care about
people's lives in there and it's hard
but if I think something is funny I'm
just gonna do it you know and um and
this whole thing about like I'm not
really into you know the whole thing
about bullies and all that I like
bullies because you are a bully no no
I'm not a bully I was I was always
bullied I was bullied too I was bullied
brutally in high school and I think
those bullies I want to tell kids that
are being bullied in high school go
listen like nerds
yeah it's tough now but when in your 20s
that bully is gonna be a doorman at a
club and you're gonna make millions of
dollars throw Wadden yeah when I'm
saying is that life changes and shifts
and bullies generally don't they turn
into there's a comic Michael anoche
who's Chris Delia's opener no no Chi I
feel like you could have been a bullying
in high school right bro a jock but
that's why I treat him like [ __ ] because
I know that I speak for the bullied the
Nerds and you seem to think that I'm not
a bully
what you just said that I was a bully
yeah bully you think I'm a bully I think
you believe some of us that's a
troubling you don't even know what
bullying means then because my shits
love Oh hard love that's not even hard
love it's pure love all just peer to
peer has come yeah yeah if you saw if
love love in physical form is me Wow
also check out love on Netflix season
jump terrible on you stop saying that I
just saw it
[Music]